aujourd'hui jean jacques morel
bonjour j'ai simon jouera tous est la
bataille des prochaines élections
municipales et bien lancée dans
certaines communes y compris dans celles
où les candidats potentiels ne sont
toujours pas déclaré à saint denis par
exemple l'opposition s'est saisie du
rapport de la chambre régionale des
comptes qui s'est intéressé à la gestion
la commune mais qui mènera la bataille
contre le maire sortant gilbert annette
lui même senti candidats d'ailleurs
quelle conséquence les bouleversement du
paysage politique national et local
auront-elles à la réunion à l'aube de
cette nouvelle campagne électorale sur
le fond qu'est ce qui différencie
aujourd'hui les acteurs de cette
bataille pour le pouvoir qui s'annonce
jean jacques morel conseiller municipal
d'opposition de saint denis conseiller
départemental de la majorité porte
parole d'objectif réunion le parti de
didier robert est avec nous sur la
première jusqu'à 13 heures vos questions
au 02 62 99 2000 à partir de 12h45
jean jacques morel bonjour bonjour est
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
l'actualité c'est donc ce rapport de la
chambre régionale des comptes sur la
gestion de la commune de saint denis
depuis 2000 13 communes où vous êtes élu
de l'opposition il a été question de ce
rapport durant la semaine dernière parce
qu'il ya des fuites dans le dans la
presse plus au conseil municipal de
samedi
c'est un rapport qui pour vous et pingre
assez durement le la gestion du maire
actuel j'hibernais tu dis c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire
en réalité il s'agit d'un rapport
incendiaire qui stigmatisent jeu des
points essentiels c'était un des points
qui toucha au règles de transparence aux
règles morales publiques la gestion du
maire socialiste et de son équipe et
j'en veux pour exemple les règles sur
les marchés publics donc à nouveau saint
denis a des soucis avec des affaires
marchés publics
on considère que le code des marchés
publics n'a pas été respecté est-ce que
ça doit s que ça doit aujourd'hui ce que
c'est la justice
[Musique]
ces chiffres qui disent ah et dis pas
que ça il dit que s'agissant des
recrutements et de recrutement familiaux
bon je suis honnête on a nommé trois ou
quatre on sait pas trop parce que la
phrase jours c'était 4 au conseil c'est
étroit
en réalité il semble qu'une dizaine
d'emplois familiaux soit épinglée par la
chambre mais ça aussi c'est un délit
pénal
c'est de la prise illégale d'intérêts ça
veut dire que vous attendez vous
attendez la justice tranche sur ces
questions là où est ce que vous êtes
assez spéciale et sélectionner notre
planète appartient de de ceux de se
défendre
il se débat comme un beau diable mais
les faits sont têtus
ce qu'écrit la chambre qui ne règle pas
le compte politique
ça correspond au moins pour une part
temps pensé à la réalité maintenant il
bénéficie la présomption d'innocence le
plan pénal
ce que j'ai cru comprendre que
l'autorité de poursuite à savoir le
procureur public de salles unis a ouvert
une enquête préliminaire
mais je vous avoue que je ne sais pas
pourquoi l enquête a été ouverte
donc nous ne serons attentifs en savoir
sur quoi on enquête et qui est mis en
cause
c'est pourquoi sur la gestion de deux
lettres de la commune gilbert net se
défend
le rapport pointe des dépenses
importantes notamment sur la gratuité de
la cantine
je lui parlais se défendre oui d'accord
ça coûte cher mais moi j'assume c'est
une bonne idée qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous alors là c'est différent
comme critique la sueur c'est sur la
gestion la chambre attention la santé
financière de la commune s'est beaucoup
dégradée notamment parce que les usagers
ne paient pas le prix d'un service
public et on peut discuter effectivement
sur le bien fondé ou pas de baisser le
prix de la cantine et vous savez c'est
driller drake pour avant ta passion à
ses finances publiques
soit c'est l'usager qui paye quand vous
avez la piscine par exemple vous payer
un euro à l'entrée on peut aussi le
chili que ça sera gratuit et qui va
payer
tessa sera lui ce sera le contribuable
un donc c'est plus l'usagé mais c'est
contribuer à ces impôts et les impôts
fonciers à saint denis et annette les a
augmentées il y est présent donc si vous
voulez moi je suis de ceux qui pensent
que l'usager doit toujours participé aux
séries public il sole ici parce que
prenons l'exemple de la piscine la
petite manip à la piscine la piscine
simply soit considéré que l'usager a pu
compter sur la cantine votre position
faute de quoi de france générosités de
démagogie à rendre tout laissé le public
gratuit voilà sur la cantine
l'incontinent si vous voulez y avait
déjà une dégressivité très forte quand
on est content
en fonction des revenus moi je peux je
vous comprend effectivement que
contrôler un peu de moyens on paye très
peu vrac on paye 0 je considère que pour
les lits les classes moyennes notamment
et ne parlons pas aller les classes
aisées je trouve normal que on contribue
on contribue je pas dit qu'on parlera
pas parce que le système par la cantine
ces grands gros un tir la carte qui paye
un tir amérique il supporte et un tiers
le l'usager qui à chaque fois pour je
trouve pas scandaleux que dans une
municipalité
quand il ya un service public et
d'acquis et le offert et bien que
l'usager paie on sait que c'est une
petite somme qu'on puisse dispenser les
plus pauvres de cette contribution je le
conçois
autrement les impôts autrement sont là
pour combler difficile et que dit la
chambre aujourd'hui l'endettement est
passé entre 2013 et 2017 de 5 ans à 10
ans c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
capacité de 10 ans pour rembourser et la
côte d'alerté est atteinte
est-ce que sur un autre point qui
ressemble peut-être insu des cantines
c'est la gratuité des transports pour
certaines catégories qui était mise en
place là encore est ce que selon vous ça
reste malgré tout une bonne idée parce
qu'on sait qu'il faut développer les
transports en commun parce qu'on sait
que ça peut être le prix peut être
éventuellement rédhibitoire pour
certaines personnes qu'est-ce que quelle
est votre position
ma position est claire je suis favorable
à la gratuité des transports pour toute
une série de franges de la population
pronovost de l'emploi voilà pour
l'instant c'est à cet âge et les
demandeurs d'emploi les séparent du chan
est qu'il a fait l'esclavagé fut
longtemps les scolaires
bien sûr parce qu'il faut on est dans un
dans un un climat d'apoplexie
embouteillages peut plus circuler
donc oui ça c'est une bonne mesure mais
si vous me demandez s'il vous reste que
vous êtes favorable à ce que ça soit
tout en gratuit pour tout le monde je
vous dirais non parce que si c'est pas
l'usagé qu'ils payent une partie encore
iphone l'indus oubliez les impôts vont
devoir payer et vous de voir encore
augmenter
ma position est très claire là-dessus
favoriser là le transport en commun oui
et notamment la gratuité pour les je
dirais les catégories de population les
plus fragiles ceux qui ont le plus
besoin
toujours à propos de ce rapport il est
pointé aussi la question des grands
chantiers notamment donné aux la
nouvelle entrée ouest de saint-denis où
est-ce qu'on en est on a perdu parce
qu'on se souvient de des annonces on se
souvient de de la région
reprenant une partie du dossier vous qui
êtes aux consignes bien sûr toute la
campagne gilbert annette en 2014 puisque
j'étais sur la liste michel lagourgue et
à fusionner au deuxième partiel de
monsieur victoria est en passe de nous
on avait un beau projet ne vous
arrachera complètement refait des arbres
un mode de transport silencieux
une piscine de mer six ans après 12 ans
parce que ça fait 12 ans qu'il est aux
affaires
rien c'est à dire qu'on a on n'a
quasiment pas avancer alors oui
effectivement la région à aux piles de
cire main et a enfin pu convaincre
gibert des deux si une co-maîtrise
d'ouvragé pour lancer les études parce
que là on est en sortie j'y serai pas
finie et l'entrée ouest elle vais pas
commencer
ça fait un moment que cet accord était
signé sans nez ou non parce que très
longtemps gibert net à traîner les pieds
prenez l'exemple de la position qui
n'est pas une commune du bord politique
de didier robert
il ya la région a signé il ya belle
lurette avec adam iront ville un accord
pour aménager tout la sortie de l'euro
du littoral côté ouest à saint denis le
maire de l'équipe socialiste parce que
c'est pas que gilbert gress est mal
barrés un forfait qui était encore à
l'époque parlementaire ils ont traîné
des pieds pour quelle raison je n'en
sais rien aujourd'hui qui payent le prix
en douze ans je n'en ai que la
circulation tuent les transports hassani
rien d'important mais effet on annonce
un téléphérique pour plus tard mais en
12 ans et eu aucun axe
aucun transport en commun rien n'a été
fait j'ajoute que on nous parle d'un
tramway à écouter au bout de deux ans il
serait temps de s'en soucier
on va reparler justement de du
transparentes dans un moment et les
différents projets qui qui qui existe
dans toujours dans le dans le dans le
rapport il est question aussi de pôle
océan sarah un sujet sur lequel vous
avez l'habitude de vous exprimer dans
l'opposition là encore ça n'avance pas
qu'est ce qui se passe je pense que ça
n'intéresse pas gilbert annette
il s'intéresse à l'éducation et ça c'est
bien il ya eu des choses dans les écoles
damman sur l'onglet et
l'opposition on applaudit il s'intéresse
au social il fait énormément de
logements sociaux parce que ça lui
permet d'avoir une forme de le clientèle
qui lui permet ensuite de consolider sa
position aux élections en réalité parce
qu'on maîtrise d'économie il est tombé
vous la commune signé la deuxième plus
forte demande il ya toujours de grandes
on est la deuxième à la réunion on qu'on
a un plot en matière de logements
sociaux qui est très important il faut
faire et le manceau une évidence il faut
faire aussi le vent que les classes
moyennes
parce que peut pas acheter à saint denis
ces prochains et font trop riche pour
bénéficier dans le jean alesi dr alors
comment fait on panique les classes
moyennes le saint denis qui vont à la
position qu'ils vont à sainte marie
c'est pas ma vision des choses
donc j'ai lu la lettre ne s'intéresse
pas à l'économie par une zone d'activité
depuis 12 ans des entreprises qui saint
denis ils vont chercher du foncier a
d'ailleurs ce qui reste la première
pierre de on est libre mais bientôt ici
bientôt aussi une grande surface pour
l'océan mais on est nourri dans le
mirage 1 aurait en réalité le projet est
toujours englué dans des recours dans
des preuves de financement puisqu'il
faut savoir que comme ça ne s'est pas
fait la collectivité doit faire des
chèques en sac ou des millions d'euros
aux contribuables
bref on est dans le véritable scandale
puisque en 12 ans quand vous balader en
au centre-ville de san ip le petit
marché vous avez de cet espace qui est
immense oui vous avez des herbes qui
sont d'un mètre de hauteur
mais rien en réalité de concret n'a été
fait durant toutes ces années
j'aurais que revient la question de
l'emploi nous avait dit à la chambre
régionale des comptes pointe du doigt
l'emploi des emplois
qui aurait pas respecté la procédure
aurait pas été respecté pour ses emplois
vous parlez de clientélisme vous parler
de deux d'emplois familiaux
là encore est ce que vous attendez que
ça ce que la justice se prononce ou est
ce que c'est une façon aussi de faire
campagne de commencer la campagne pour
la prochaine élection disant regardez
bien fait du clientélisme votez pas pour
lui d'abord il faut observer que c'est
pas l'opposition t'es levé le lièvre sa
chambre des comptes qui estime qu' il ya
plusieurs emplois je pense environ une
dizaine qui sont des personnes qui font
partie
un degré plus ou moins proche de la
famille de gilbert annette et je trouve
que c'est pas bien
bon c'est un coup de poignard porté au
pacte républicain je trouve c'est un
coup de poignard porté aux règles qui
envoie cette fonction publique
là c'est normal c'est le concours et on
a c'est pas normal qu'on ait plus de
chance un plan annette qu'hoarau et
c'est ça que j'ai pointé du doigt ou
conseils et ça constitue de surcroît un
délit pénal
un qui s'appelle la prise illégale
d'intérêts je ne sais pas s'ils veulent
enquête pénale pour tzu mais il est
clair que il ya des mères en france qui
ont été condamnés pour voir que sa jante
être un arrêt de la cour de cassation ou
un maire avait donné un ami simplement
c'est pas quelqu'un de sa famille une
délégation pour un golf et bien la
chambre criminelle de la cour de
cassation dit c'est interdit c'est la
prime égale vous n'avez pas le droit de
faire ça donc oui moi je dis très
clairement c'est enfin familiaux 1
ils sont pénalement répréhensibles ils
sont illicites
et en 3 ils sont choquants dans un pays
où autour de jeunes diplômés qualifiés
sont au chômage et aurait bien aimé e
occuper ces emplois
g berne êtes vous répondre 10 ans jean
jacques morel ferait bien de regarder du
côté de didier robert dont vous êtes le
porte parole sous-entendus finalement
ces pratiques là elle existe partout y
compris dans votre camp alors sa réponse
elle est irrecevable pour la bonne et
simple raison que quand il parle
de là des pousses de didier robert salut
moi j'ai connu
corinne robert elle travaillé au
département il ya vingt ans elle était
déjà fonctionnaire territorial et je
connaissais même pas encore voilà quand
il est comme ça longtemps cabinet de la
région mais parce que si vous voulez
était déjà fonctionner c'était son but
il a été recruté quand elle tant que
dans la fonction publique par didier
elle était elle était au département et
ensuite elle a fait connaissance du
diderot bien quand elle est partie le
comprends mais je dirais c'est pas le
président de région qu'il a regoûté vous
voyez ce que je veux dire
moi quand anne est avec ses enfants
ainsi nord 1 qui travaillait à la mairie
je trouve que c'était pas le mieux qu'on
puisse faire mais ce n'était pas illégal
il a arrêté et il les a tuées
ouais bon bien sûr parce que c'est la
loi mais jamais le président de région
n'a recruté directement quelqu'un de sa
famille allaient là on parle quand même
d'une dizaine d'employés il y a quand
même cette question qui reste est ce que
est ce que le clientélisme peut être
bannis de la pratique politique à la
réunion dans toutes les collectivités où
est ce que on va continuer comme ça
parce que de toute façon quelles que
soient les lois qu'on met en place
visiblement ça a du mal à vous parler du
clientélisme du népotisme
parce que bush et sa famille c'est du
népotisme c'est pas du clientélisme oui
ce que je dis rien les doigts mais alors
le lait petit c'est un délit pénal
mâcon renforcer les textes je fait qu'il
le soit encore davantage en tout cas je
vais vous dire que je suis de ceux qui
pensent qu'on fait pas de la politique
pour embaucher ses enfants ça c'est la
première chose le clientélisme c'est
compliqué de l'éradiquer parce qu'on est
dans une île qui nous les gens font
pauvres aux listes hâtive bon mois
j'avais très peu de voyage était face à
une ministre soutenu par monsieur
annette maire de saint-denis la part
communale donc le crâne et barèges qu'on
peut mois distribuer des emplois aidés à
l'époque on allait distribuer des
centaines les mois qui précèdent
l'élection il conclue pendant tout le
tour et il ya des gens bailly qui
prennent un petit film suit montréal où
on est en difficulté on pense et on peut
aider
vous voyez c'est très compliqué dans un
territoire qui est aussi pauvre de
lutter contre ce type de pratiques
et j'ajoute ça se fait aussi sur les
logements sociaux qui seront distribués
selon des critères qui sont pas toujours
un très très très très et c'est qu'il
est très transparent qu'il faut c'est
dans toutes les communes faut s'y
atteler
ça se passe par contre je sais pas si je
suis pas je suis pas là pour distribuer
niveau des mauvaises autres moi je suis
en position 1 saint denis je suis
candidat parfois cette chance à denis il
est par contre assez il ya il ya cinq
ans hollis créative et il ya deux ans
parfois avec bonheur est parfois au
contraire avec mahler mais si vous
voulez je constate que les maires en
place et c'est très compliqué de ses
réponses et général comme j'ai fait moi
contre l'appareil comme elle la plupart
des conseillers généraux sont des
émanations de la mairie en place et la
réponse est très claire en cui il faut
il faut lutter contre ces pratiques là
les éradiquer complètement pourra jamais
empêcher un électeur d'être
reconnaissant un maire doit ranger en
route devant chez lui ou de le voir
devenir un logement social et ça moi je
peux le comprendre
jean jacques morel comment va la droite
dionysienne une partie des troupes par
rejoindre la république en marche
comment comment ça se passe pour cette
droite dionysienne et pour vous mais
vous savez que les phares marche est un
mouvement qui une spécificité c'est
qu'ils y mord à la frh la drass et sur
la gauche il vous aura pas échappé que
gilbert annette a favorisé
l'émergence une franche gauche à la
public en revanche alors on sait plus
trop puisque barèges et des pros macro
maintenant est tire à boulet rouge le
président macro donc apparemment elle
avait mis en berne sa carte du parti
socialiste elle à ressort vous avez des
élus socialistes donc qu'ils disent
maintenant on n'est plus socialiste est
en marche
donc ces départs et de nouveau à droite
vous avez chicago qui avait adhéré il ya
longtemps où il ya deux ans la
république en marche forcée vite si elle
a adhéré plus récemment
donc moi je me félicite que la droite
soit également présente à la république
en marché comme moi c est lui qui se
qualifie de santis tu puisses j'allais
dire avoir une sensibilité est davantage
proche de la nôtre qu'être des des
godillots du gilbert des clous ou de
erika barèges et vous vous diriez à la
république en marche alors je pense
qu'il faut jamais dire jamais parce que
je ne sais pas comment la vie politique
a évolué en france
aujourd'hui force est de constater que
la pépite en marche est devenu un parti
libéral qu'il occupe cette frange de
santé même de centre-droit s'il ya des
élus importants les des finances par
exemple qui sont là bas moi aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il faut tenter de je sais
pas si ça sera par exemple valérie
pécresse si ça sera savez bertrand on à
moi je ne change pas de
mon bateau commence donc je reste un
homme de centre droit auquel sera celui
ou celle qui va incarner nous espoir à
la présidentielle en 2012 j'en sais rien
et je ne sais pas comment le mâcon va
lui même évolué vous avez aujourd'hui
pour être élu sur une ici pâli t il faut
que didier robert s'il est candidat il
est un projet qu'ils soient rassembleurs
vous dit s'il est candidat
vous êtes bien placé en tant que porte
parole de didier robert pour savoir s'il
va l'être ou pas oui je suis son porte
parole n'ont pas tous les soirs ensemble
il sent qu il a sa famille et moi la
mienne mais sans dormir soit pas d'où
vous pourriez savoir si les candidats ne
se précipitent pas sur un poste je suis
responsabilité c'est quelqu'un qui
requis et réfléchie et les dionysiens
depuis une dizaine d'années concernant
la grèce et quand ils voient ça n'y
était en panne mais il a mal au coeur
comme beaucoup le dionysien
bon maintenant franchir le pas et est ce
que il tirera les conséquences la
situation politique à saint denis c'est
à dire une équipe socialiste en fin de
règne à bout de souffle qui veut imposer
à nouveau sur l'hégémonie sur six ans un
équipe on a dit c'est le seul qui de
façon je dirais sérieux soline pourrait
dire à gilbert annette gilbert 12 ans ça
suffit et l'alternance la possibilité de
de créer une alternance à saint denis
l'alternative à saint denis quant à sa
décision
rapidement je n'en sais rien je pense
que vous savez pas lire cl de façon
intuitive je pense que la rentrée des
classes en septembre
je pense que si jean fera prises s'il
décide de se présenter à sa ligne il le
fera savoir à ce moment là ce a vu toute
façon en politique c'est pas celui qui
parle le premier c'est bien un proverbe
qui dit gros poisson tard voilà
stratégiquement il a intérêt à partir
plus tard vous croyez est ce qu'on sait
du côté de la gauche les candidats si je
perdais cirque à barèges
le fiji je sais pas moi
est ce que si si c'est dû dire au berry
va pas c'est vous qui aurez non moi je
ne serai pas candidat aux municipales
j'ai toujours dit vous savez que très
attachées à l'exercice de l'activité
professionnelle
jessica est incompatible avec le le
poste de gaza ni une responsabilité de
premier plan qui est très très
accaparante j'ajoute j'ajoute que pour
faire face à gilbert annette qui est il
se définit lui-même comme le premier des
socialistes
eh bien il faut le premier à droite le
premier d'entre nous c'est didier robert
est ce qu'on pourrait avoir cette
configuration quand même qu'il serait
très étonnante d'avoir face à face à
saint denis thomas crown hien gilbert
annette d'un côté didier robert de
l'autre tous les deux s'étant déclarés
finalement assez proche de de maquereaux
didier robert a soutenu la liste de la
république en marche pour les
européennes voilà ça fait pas vraiment
de mystère
ça serait cadencé général ses fans
bijoux 1 qu'il était lui bien la vie
politique ça dégringole parfois il ya
des aironi de l'histoire donc moi je
vois j'ai entendu cette semaine et
quelques jours gilbert annette critiqué
vertement la politique de ma console
trop duré il ya des aspects critiquable
tous les pas beaux seins on en a enlevé
quelques euros retraités ce n'était pas
une bonne chose
je comprends que nos compatriotes
mécontents alors qu'elle sera peut-être
lis ma choriste qui sera ni ça sera ni
un ni à n'être ni rue est faux parce que
l'hypothèse trois cas en tout cas un
maquereau nice est de plus ou moins 1 go
compatible
l'essentiel n'est pas là voyez je crois
c'est hull et sur local poubelles à
décalquer jeu les autres chaque élection
a sa logique politique et les
municipales se font sur un je pense
beaucoup plus à l'affectif sur un projet
politique et sur une envie finalement dû
dire tiens les socialistes par la cuy 12
ans on veut essayer autre chose
allons changer oui mais vous même vous
dit les socialistes à veut dire que
finalement il ya toutes les stations
pour les nuls opportunisme dans la
candidature notamment de barèges a dit
espérer que pas croire conduisent comme
moult revers comme vous dites et quand
il l'a éjecté a été très déçu a repris
sa carte du ps je pense en fait ce sont
des fonds des élus socialistes qui ont
enfourché le cheval du maquereau nisme
par opportunisme mais est ce qu'on
pourra vous retournez finalement moi je
suis avait été jusqu'à brad vous avez
été à droite vous avez été au sarkozysme
vous avez une époque un boulet rouge sur
sur sur macro et puis aujourd'hui à
boulet rouge sonne sauf peut-être chez
socialiste mais je n'ai jamais tiré
apprendra que vous avez été très très
critique propose une offre politique
nouvelle quand c'était pas bon je dis
c'est pas bon quand ce camp si bien j
c'est bien sûr une attaque d'habitation
je dis bravo voilà
mais bon la réunion c'est vrai que pour
l'autre guerre générale et ça je le dis
le concert église et robert nous restons
un peu sur notre faim
donc ça veut pas dire que l'on rejette
en bloc c'est fait mâcon et qu'on
considère que le modèle économique qu'il
cherche on paul virapoullé qui consiste
à user d'avoir l'expérimentation pour
développer
l'économie outre-mer eh bien on est on y
va on sait que le chômage reste à un
coût très élevé est ce que est ce que
vous vous êtes finalement d'accord avec
cette façon de faire de la politique d'
emmanuel macron qui consiste à dire
droite gauche bon il ya la droite et de
la gauche dans le même donc on peut dans
le même gouvernement dans l'âme dans la
même avancée est ce que c'est possible
ou est-ce que vous êtes attachez vous à
des valeurs de droite qui sont
incompatibles avec ce genre de politique
mais il faut distinguer les valeurs et
les partis politiques dans un parti
politique vous pouvez avoir des
sensibilités qui correspondent à des
valeurs de droite et si emmanuel lacroix
a pu ainsi présenter une partie de la
droite c'est parce que par exemple sur
la valeur de l'économie libérale essayé
de donner un peu de souffle aux
entreprises alléger certaines taxes
baisser la tva nous c'est ce qu'on
souhaitait faire et c'est ce qu'on a
peut-être pas forcément eu le courage de
faire
qu'est ce que vous voulez je suis
sarkozyste et moi j'ai oui j'ai eu
nicolas sarkozy mais il n'a pas fait
tout bien
1 il ya des réformes la tva sociale par
exemple un qui est ce qu'ils se trouvent
ces femmes qu'est ce qui vous sépare
aujourd'hui du coup de la république en
marche je pense il voulait que la
république en marche
e outre-mer n'a pas donné toute sa
mesure et nous sommes déçus de ce que la
voie de l'expérimentation qui figurait
dans le programme de didier robert aux
dernières jonas c'est à dire pouvoir
baisser la fiscalité et les taxes une
première pour déroger au droit commun
parce qu'on peut pas traiter de la même
façon un petit département comme la
réunion qui doit qu'isolé qu un
département comme le rhône ou comme
l'oise bien là on compte je considère
que la ministre de l'outre-mer et n'a
pas été à la hauteur de nos attentes
il ya eu la crise et j'ai le jeu et
quelques réponses partielles mais il
faut changer de modèle il faut aller
j'ai arrêté de jouer petit bras
la situation sociale à la réunion est
très difficile et j'ajoute que il
suffirait de pas grand chose dans
certaines communes on le voit quand il
ya des tensions sociales mais rapidement
il ya des voitures qui brûlent bref il
faut prendre à bras le corps la
situation des plus modestes à la réunion
est ce que c'est
je me différencie et les classes
moyennes c'est tout le matin ils ont
pris dans les bouchons embouteillages et
qui ne bénéficient de quasiment aucun
avantage qu'elle quel regard vous portez
vous sur l'échec du parti les
républicains aux dernières européennes
et quels rapports que vous entretenez
aujourd'hui avec les représentants des
républicains ici à la réunion notamment
michel fontaine
il n'y a aucun rapport puisque il n'y a
jamais eu de réunion publique à la
réunion
vous êtes en tant qu' en tant qu'élu je
suis plus à part entière
ce geste à des ambassades héros elle a
vu rayon des départementales des que il
lève la tête on le guillotiner il ya pas
de position dans le visage
je vais passer moi je suis pas en colère
du chef antennes j'ai simplement dit que
à part dans sa commune c'est un bon bien
de chez fontaine faut pas être manichéen
mais s'intéresse pas à la réunion
s'intéresse au sud
je suis désolé le sud ne résume pas la
situation du vide la région et je
considère que un parti politique et il
doit se structurer
1 il va s'organiser c'est si le score
réunion est presque deux fois inférieure
aux scores nationale ça veut dire qu'il
ya vraiment un problème
j'ajoute vous avez fait qu'elle allait
regarder et je jouis je moi j'aurais
souhaité qu'ils ont un nouveau président
à la leyre il n'a pas souhaité cesser
son c'est son problème mais aujourd'hui
les gens à droite ne se reconnaissent
plus dans les airs j'ajoute que depuis
le départ de vous qui est déjà mieux
c'était le mot un peu cruel
commentateurs politiques
bon la ligne politique aux tenues par
ailleurs ce front national ne ne
correspond pas une formule cruel auquel
je souscris fillon a mis la droite un
cercueil ils vous qui représentez vous
précise emerson de la ligne de feu ont
tendance à la ligne de vos qui était
trop proche de celle de l'international
vous qu'ils étaient trop puissantes iter
le trop conservatrices
ce que je vis eu l antec l'udf classe
politique auprès jean paul virapoullé
donc jean olivéra louis mais je suis
centriste européen évident humaniste
mais pas l'unanimité soit le lui dise
encore pire il lui dira réunion c'est
une adepte du parti socialiste en tout
cas sur sa tempe d'élection je le viol
est hâtive et deux ans et dont je peux
pas on peut pas si vous voulez est
également travaillé avec des gens qui se
considèrent de droite quand elles sont
candidats mais qui autrement sont des
auxiliaires du parti socialiste c'est à
dire qu'on est à saint denis au lieu-dit
à la réunion nassimah dindar
oui mais ce n'est pas une alliée de de
didier robert est bon nassimah dindar a
exercé une prison du conseil général
elle a fait des choses tout faut pas
noircir le bilan des gens y ait des
choses intéressantes notamment sur les
personnes handicapées sur le sur la
mutuelle
mais en tant que s'ils voulaient qu'on
positionnement politique c'est par une
partenaire fiable donc on souhaite pour
de vils pour les municipales de la salle
ni travailler avec des gens sur un
projet politique pour servir la réunion
des partenaires qui sont fiables oui
vous faut des partenaires ça reste comme
les défis de l'ère fiable ça c'est
objectif réunion il y aura des alliés il
y aura une plateforme gt municipal 1
avec des alliés ça ça peut être des
partenaires centre-droit centre gauche
alarmant peut être un partenaire
possible à saint denis
d'accord ce qu'il est clairement
opposé à gilles burnett il n'y a pas de
doute là dessus tous les opposants à
avoir des partenaires et évidemment
comme michel lagourgue la république en
marche
on s'attendait à voir aussi des gens de
la société civile
mais ça veut dire pardon s'engager mais
ça se tourner la page ça signifie que au
niveau réunionnais pour ses prochaines
municipales y aura pas de plateforme de
la droite celle qui avait permis à la
droite de remporter le conseil régional
le conseil départemental
cette plateforme là c'est mort c'est
fini en politique rien n'est jamais
écrit al avance c'est pas parce que je
vous dis que les républicains ça marche
pas la réunion que on ne peut pas parler
avec michel fontaine
quitte à questionner les politiques à la
rue il faut pouvoir parler avec lui du
coup je considère pas il vous reste neuf
mois c'est dire qu'il vous dit qu'on
n'est pas en train de parler avec lui
mais c'est pas des comptes a que vous
qui passez par mois donc il faut pas y
avoir des oeillères
il faut pas non plus on ressasse sans
arrêt et puissent passer moi je
considère que si elle met alors un qu'il
offre une gamme qui m'ont président au
département il fait partie se le
permettre bien sûr et où il vous aura
pas échappé qu'il a appelé à voter ses
fans qui joue aussi pour autant ça reste
notre politique de centre droit comme
moi même comme didier robert et il est
pas terrible ce parent et vous avez vu
casse à paris
la plate forme est sûre s'il vous
employez bon en tout cas le
rassemblement du centre de la droite
c'était possible pourquoi pas sur
d'autres communes à propos de la
position de cyrille melchior
on a du mal à comprendre quand même
cette posture en position par rapport à
quoi par rapport à un vote pour les
européennes
avec la république en marche mais en
même temps il reste très proche et
soutenu par michel fontaine et on se
souvient que il y avait une opposition
au sein du conseil départemental lors de
son élection en très bonne position le
candidat de la gauche est totalement
absente le département puisque il ya
belle lurette les restes et anti compris
quand il ya des soucis mais ce qui est
le retrait intervient à présenter de
candidat à présenter parental c'est dire
comme vous avez une gauche qui
descendait ce qu'a toujours de droite
alors ces départs que vous aviez deux
candidats bon aloi les découvrir et
partager avec notamment la gauche qui a
fait la différence a été lu bon et il
est d'évidence il n'en reste pas moins
que c'est quelqu'un c'est un bon
président c'est quelqu'un avec qui on
peut parler c'est un homme le dossier de
l'ouverture
c'était un final en politique et moi je
considère que les municipales passe
notamment par l'adoubement si on peut
s'exprimer ainsi le lit des robes encore
pour constituer des listes d'union
droite centre et même pourquoi pas un
peu de la des listes de rassemblement
sans michel foucault faire face non j'ai
pas dit ça je pense que je le ressens le
parti est dirigé le refus jarretelles
potentiellement engagé dans la politique
à saint pierre
je vous avais pas entendu émettre des
critiques contre la politique municipale
de michel fontaine je ne sais pas
rappelle d'ailleurs moi je suis élue à
saint denis sa vie un programme qui dit
chacun chez soi et les vaches seront
bien gardées
je voudrais votre avis sur certains ya
certains grands dossiers qui mériterait
un consensus ou un travail comment t'as
fait au niveau de l'ensemble du
territoire et qui sont parfois ces
dossiers justement mise à mal par
l'opposition entre didier robert et
michel fontaine on pense à la gestion
des déchets par exemple il ya de tout
des personnalités politiques que j'ai
reçus dans cette émission tous disent
c'est une histoire de personnes c'est un
conflit de personnes
c'est pas un conflit politique ont
parfois on peut surmonter ça compte
notamment vers centraliser le rsa au
département comme pour la guyane et
comme pour bayonne parce que l'état ne
nous payer parce qu'il était dû
allez surtout en faillite on a pu
obtenir et le président melchior avec le
soutien des élus quelle que soit leur
couleur on a pu playlist aussi à paris
après un gain de cause la prof quelque
chose qui se font sur les déchets il ya
une divergence est vrai sur
l'appréciation lire et de ses projets
puisque le projet écologique de 10,0
grèce et c'est un projet qui est marqué
la préservation l'environnement des
avantages en nature berne ne veut pas je
veux que le projet d'incinérateur qui
est déjà bien engagée oui c'est vrai que
moi je suis pas le seul arbitre je
dirais entre des personnalités
politiques de la réunion 1
mais le il ya eu si vous voulez je prend
sûrement des soucis le dialogue
il ya eu un des soucis par rapport à
l'épreuve de rivalités politiques
ça peut exister je reste persuadé que
l'environnement l'écologie la
préservation je dirais de notre île elle
est davantage présente aujourd'hui chez
tous les élus et que le projet du dit
robert qui consiste à dire
l'incinérateur c'est déjà mieux par
rapport à aujourd'hui
mais ça laisse quand même des résidus il
ya d un côté d'oisifs il ya des
nuisances à le projet meilleur donc faut
pas désespérer le les mettre autour
d'une table et environ 10,6 en termes de
financement qu'est ce que le l'union
européenne et l'état choisiront
vous avez parlé de transport tout à
l'heure notamment sur saint denis
actuellement deux projets
en parallèle un an porté par la région
emportée par la cinor celui de la région
étant soren ride
qui passerait par le boulevard sud est
puis en centre ville intra mot est porté
par la cinor projet tramway on a
l'impression de là encore que il ya des
querelles qui empêche une vision globale
on n'a pas d'argent pour faire de
projets c'est pour ça que je suis ce
qu'ils souhaitent que la majorité change
un seigneur mars prochain et donc que la
cinor change de 20 pour qu'on puisse
parler plus facilement avec le nouveau
président de région parce que je sais
c'est une information que je vous donne
si dur bête est candidat à saint denis
il restera évidemment six ans vers saint
denis il sera pas question produits de
migrer votre responsabilité
donc oui on ne peut pas se permettre
d'avoir deux projets que les projets
évoluent en termes de nombre de stations
qui avait un écartement des rails qui
est un tracé qui soit différent ça me
paraît être être la logique et le bon
sens mais on n'entendra pas de le projet
sanad a eu on ne pouvait pas trouver
l'argent et pourtant aujourd'hui six
lycées pas de projets ces deux projets
on est tout au début si vous voulez les
le ces deux modes de transports en
commun ils vont pas qu'ils voient
l'année prochaine
on est jeudi moyen terme / / / / 4 5 ans
qu'avec le budget de communication viven
les choses on se qualifier mais il est
évident que vous avez clavier me donnera
raison
en matière de transport sur saint denis
il ya un problème majeur parce qu'on est
on est scotché dans les embouteillages
surtout le matin et le soir aux portes
ville un don qui a besoin d'un de
transport ferré est ce ce transport il
devrait qu'unique unifiée on pourra pas
se permettre d'avoir deux c'est
impossible mais parce que le dialogue
aujourd'hui avec le président de la
cinor et dialogue se fait par quelqu'un
a les yeux qui s'est déclarée très
proche pour toi et comme disait ma
collègue au conseil samedi matin il ya
beaucoup plus de démocratie à la cinor à
la mairie de saint-denis où quand on
prend la parole on se fait huer à tel
point que j'ai dû abandonner demandé à
la jeunesse ont été aussi haut dans un
conseil général bakayoko
gilbert annette d'accord il s'est
maintenu à la cinor contre le raid
qu'ils peuvent aller jusqu ici qui avait
une règle tournante c'est sa
responsabilité
mais le c'est quelqu'un qui faisait
partie de sa base hier qu' il doit sera
toujours moi aujourd'hui je peux pas
considérer que gérald maillot est un
allié de la droite et du centre plaisir
à venir et vous considérez que l'eps
aussi il ne dément me disant mais mon
cher jean jacques c'est comme ça qu'il
m'appelle et je dis mon cher gérald bien
siku considère qu'aujourd'hui le crâne
est saint-denis sainte-marie est devenu
est en face de toi avec le plus proche
de nous il faut bien de rejoindre ça si
vous êtes tous la républiqu e en marche
au jour ses satellites si vous oubliez
conseiller général saint denis donc
c'est quelqu'un qui est quand même un
pas politique
on verra si pour secret sera sa position
sur les municipales mais moi je
considère pas ces parts et demi ça reste
un adversaire politique
même si c'est un adversaire qui est qui
on peut parler on parle depuis tout à
l'heure on arrive en toute fin
d'émission on parle depuis tout à
l'heure de ces municipales et finalement
de bagarres d'appareils un aussi entre
entre les différents clans ou quant à
droite avec le parti socialiste vous
avez beaucoup fustigé aujourd'hui c'est
comme si il y avait deux événements qui
finalement n'avait pas de prise sur ce
scrutin municipal qui sont le score
extrêmement élevé du rassemblement
national lors des dernières élections et
la forte mobilisation des gilet jaune
qui ont demandé à faire la politique
autrement c'est comme si ça ça n'avait
pas existé
bien d'accord avec vous tout ce qui
s'est passé à la région sous les genoux
avec le conseil représentatif c'est
consultatif consultatif pardon citoyens
ces personnes qui siègent
c'est intéressant elles vont prendre
connaissance elles vont voir que c'est
pas facile de jouer des dossiers publics
qu'est les obstacles tout le monde n'est
pas d'accord que 5 août que les budgets
seront pas limités donc oui et cette
prise de conscience
quand le président de jouer à geler le
prix du carburant détaxé pardon sur le
carburant c'est pas lui
une détaxe les années à venir de
conscience mais au delà rien de durable
ne peut se faire sans l'état
c'est pour ça que je considère que le
gouvernement doit davantage se pencher
sur l'outre-mer qui restent en
difficulté qui restent en souffrance
le vote du rassemblement national pour
le rassemblement national
ici à la réunion ça vous a surpris 3%
partout la samah parce que le prix
puisque déjà peut-être d'autres
officiels aux présidentielles il avait
un espoir énorme et moi vous savez je
[Musique]
m'étonne plus je mangeais souvent
travaillé à mayotte et 10 des
travailleurs
quand vous voyez qu'il est ce que le
front national fait 45% à mayotte
donc il ya beaucoup de misère beaucoup
de révolte et un sentiment plus ou moins
justifiées que les politiques n'ont pas
toujours fait ce qu'il fallait faire le
leur ascension n'a jamais été au pouvoir
et par les temps qui courent c'est un
avantage parce qu'on peut faire miroiter
aux gens des choses en disant il ya qu'à
faut qu'on
mais on sait bien que ça se passe pas
comme ça et notamment sur l'europe on
voit que bon par une beigne pas
forcément arriver à constituer ce grand
groupe elle souhaité ce que je veux dire
c'est que chaque élection
sa logique politique et qu'on veut pas
pareil aux municipales que aux
européennes vous dites aux gens il faut
encore croire à la politique qu'il faut
encore aller voter parce que voilà c'est
aussi ça le débat il faut croire il faut
avoir confiance en nous je dis aux
réunionnais aux jeunes et moins jeunes
qui nous écoutent les confiance en vous
et une confiance en vos enfants à leur
capacité bâtir de construire il faut on
appartient grand public ce n'est pas la
france
la construction européenne c'est ce qui
nous permet de peser face à des
mastodontes comme la chine ou l'inde
donc on a des atouts considérables
regarder le cernil there qui existe dans
le servir et la réunion reste quand même
privilégié donc faut pas toujours voir
que le verre à moitié vide
1 vous savez j'aime bien cette
expression quand je me regarde je
m'inquiète quand je me compare je me
rassure donc et ils ont confiance et
jason winer politique un et je dois nos
compatriotes d'être vigilants et mais de
penser à la réunion parce que c'est ça
qui est important
vous me confirmer en un mot vous ne
serez pas candidat moi je vous espérait
que didier robert le sera et nous dira
ça à la rentrée mais vous avez assez
bien résumé ma position aujourd'hui et
est ce que ce que je peux vous dire
merci d'avoir et il avait ajouté ce
lundi politique demain à la même heure
rendez-vous comme toutes les semaines
avec le club de la presse passé une
excellente journée sur la première dans
un instant ses musiques puisque ce ougna
vient d'entrer en studio
la première à mafate 82 points de 12h15
à 13h le club de la presse sur la
première on va parler des élections
européennes qui font de l'accord
chauriens shop une chose il faut pas
croire qu'il y avait une vraie tentative
de conjonction entre didier robert et la
paix